go to Uncle that indeed we talked about
new generation and today we are very
happy to have Lou Jean late ladies to
have an interview aging is the most the
person that attracts the most attention
in the last of five to six years in
China I think in business sector in
China he's a well kind of food I go per
person and in early 1990s I think about
100 people who had access to internet in
the early 80s night at night is and a
few of them still a state in the
internet sector like the Jaguar and ding
lei lei Jun started his investment I
think in 1990 enjoy you who partnered
with Amazon in China later because the
venture capital concept was introduced
in china in two thousand only legend is
also renowned for the two thousand the
one who launched the dashami cellphone
and legend is the one of leading purse a
person who invested again the red ocean
to start the smartphone manufacturing i
remember in 2001 in shenzhen conference
who he showed me his cell me cell phone
at that time I didn't believe in his
success because there was ever so there
were so many big players including
motorola nokia arison including apple
and so many big players battling in this
field however as a new player who had no
experience in the sector I really think
his cell phone
was manufacture was risky however in the
later years we found he really brought
us some surprises I think there's a
process his story is his the process is
story full of surprises now now it's
2016 let's back to the 2000-2010 how
would you feel your cell phone at that
time he said back to the year 2010 when
I started to show me cell phone I
thought about it before quite a long
time today the business compared to six
years ago when i started this young my
cell phone was almost a similar story
but a much larger than what I expected
he said you thought about today's
business the size of it as well as the
ecosystem that you started he said
legend said I thought about the business
model the feasibility as well as the new
approach whether it would succeed in
China I remember that time that you
mentioned the 7 key words such as a
dedicated fast and reputation and others
so how would you review these keywords
what is the row of the keywords in the
business success he said I applied to
the Internet thinking to the
manufacturing of cell phones after so
many years now many people thought
internet thinking is a technical
approach only in back to 2000 where I
worked on DeJoria com I thought internet
is only something technical when i sold
my shares to amazon and i thought about
it for one year now i think is more than
a
technical way is a methodology how would
you apply it in turn thinking to find
solutions to the physical issues then I
try to think what had the applications
of hinted thinking that can have
emerging successful business now people
talk about today and there were many
writings and literatures about it but I
summarizes the a different perspective
how to apply it in terms thinking I
summarizes it with the key for key words
of dedication and two extremes and
reputation as a fastness the high speed
i think when i work on show me cellphone
i implemented these two keywords well
quite might be different from others
point of view it seems that sell me is
working on everything i think there were
two major comments he said well I want
him to show me his application of not
thinking to the traditional
manufacturing how many people I think
who had consensus of the fact and
consequence day this trend has an impact
on the manufacturing sector even
globally not too long ago lace ian wrote
about the wrote about to the show me's
story I think that's also a contribution
but now we had two other arguments first
days the show me successfully applied to
the internet thinking to the
manufacturing such a dedication fast
nessa well however there were two things
arguable firstly it's a technical issue
I remember back to the year 2013 you had
a better with dr. Zia now reviewed as
abstracted to argument versus internet
thinking versus the technical approach
now the second argument ISA from very
beginning show me worked on the cell
phone then back to the ecosystem like
the electric cook and the Joan and other
products now how would you elaborate on
what do you think of the expansion first
days the technology second to a psycho
system of show me let's analyze it one
by one legend said I think many people
or in the past six years we were
dedicated to our own business because
the Internet can penetrate directed to
the automated users in the last few
years we didn't spend much time
communicating to the public who we are
and what why do you we had some press
releases usually product launch but
seldom we had two interviews with the
media but taking this opportunity I want
to share with you what we want to do
back to the year 2010 we thought China
was the manufacturing center and the
manufacturer a lot of products however
our products were not generally accepted
by the world many of you think that the
product was of low quality and of other
issues so at that time we thought how to
make great products with the dedication
which the artisan spirits and now many
entrepreneurs would like to make a great
product but only few of them succeed I
think the point is China on the whole
has a lower operation efficiency so our
critical point is to improve the
efficiency from the rd to manufacturing
marketing and the service so only with
the high efficiency we can have
successful differentially to the
products how would you improve the
efficiency I think there is a
correlation between them for example
take the shirt x expand probably the
cost is a 100 but sewed for 1000 arm be
in the store suppose if you want to sell
for 500 KO salads for same products for
500 R&B no well only you can cut down
the cost 250 rmb still 10 times the
retail prices so the that's the practice
a great product I think the calls to
manufacturing cost is high and to the
retail and it's very expensive the
consumer cannot afford it such a product
can not sell well then if you want to
sell good greater product you must
improve the whole efficiency so our
approach to to revolutionary lies the
process pretty much like a half century
ago when Walmart launched the reform for
example Adam sixty-five percent of
margin and then all senior sem changed
the bat and again 20 years make walmart
as the world number one so other key
issue is to improve the efficiency 25
years ago costco emerged with the higher
efficiency so i think if we can
challenge the global issue improve the
overall efficiency with the only few
percentage points to complete the whole
process so with that we first tried cell
phone
manufacturing and the nature of it is to
make the Muji product in the
manufacturing sector so back to the year
2010 you targeted not only cell phone
but also others right yes so how to make
the Muji product in the high-tech sector
costco has a 4,000 asking you if you
make a store and if you only have one
cell phone then your traffic will be
very low the visitors were very limited
six years ago I think we must have at
least 50 as he used possible to attract
enough with traffic then based on this
idea we first started show me doubt net
now she'll me family and previous
trouser we believe will very exciting
and inspiring and for one month the
sales per square meter is was the fifty
percent higher than that he in the App
Store and so we may need only six to
five to six percent of alpha to complete
the sales process I think that will be a
great success let me explain the t-shirt
issue from 100 to 1000 because the
distribution cost is very high and if
can now sell well that the warehouse
calls the inventory has culture will be
added to the final retail price that's
why from 100 to 1000 and so you want to
work out the inventory house warehouse
issue and how would you cut down the
cost make it a flat previous 12 is
ecomme right you have a might calm that
is a big e commerce so you doom doomy
that you want to start with the physical
stores and with that be a outlet he says
I will try both online
and alpha line today salma calm is that
our core issue that director sales
director ecom the second is a year in
the major stores of major city will will
start will open some Shami stores and
way while playing is you know five to
six stores for you to city in a major
more sophomores and each one will be 250
square meters we now have one year Hondo
city this why we try to have hundreds of
stores or even more but this is well on
the sauce is very good well we can say
that each Xiaomi store for the first day
will have at least 1 million RMB sales
and it's only from the 250 square meters
the first month is always very
successful and profitable so for the
last a few months trouser the cost
percentage is a four percent is usually
is thirty to forty percent for the
regular stores so if we can expand this
we can not only succeed in the income
but also the offline store we will have
our great efficiency optimization so
with that a great product will be
distributed to similar the cost of the
manufacturing only few percentage points
so I think if we if we can find
solutions to improve the efficiency we
can succeed because the difficulty where
the distribution is the how you operate
how you cut down the operational costs
so the first thing yum you would like to
do is to make itself as a Muji in the
high tech sector so that to entertain
everyone with a low cost you know
consumers can access your product at a
lower price there might be some
misleading stories because yummy is
quite a arguable controversial
company hotline probably I encourage all
of you to experience I think in our
store probably you know many people who
are never show me users are criticizing
us I'm fully confident for that and you
encourage your experience so in the last
five years show me is dedicated to the
ecomm and started the offline stores
only from this year you mentioned the
dedication I think many people don't
think it'll well because actually we
make other choices we give up something
and to take something for example the
ecological system what focus our this
Muji business model in a high-tech
sector without enough ice cubes we can
also track in out for traffic so this is
one thing has been missing by the public
we're not just a cell phone company we
are a retail branding company I have one
more question about the echo chain you
mentioned I understanding about the
ecological environment means that it you
need to exist in a more micro business
environment I see it as a presentation
of the commercial ability and the supply
chain and the distribution chain of one
company very where it will be a close to
circle if it is a circle then it means
the whole chain is very vertical
vertical I've never discussed this with
you before but there are some comments
saying show me he's producing a lot of
products like the routers like this
sweets switched and the AC in cars and
cell phones and you wanted to develop of
include the all those products into one
circle is what you are thinking now for
example you have the one products now
now and in the future you may have tens
thousands or hundreds
products if you see these products as a
circle then what are the relations
between among them and the water the
relations between them and other
products this is I think if you look at
the show me network in the dashami
family as a retail brand you mentioned a
lot about the Muji it is not an Internet
company so means the products of muji
are not related together they are united
under one concept or a concept of a
lifestyle however for xiaomi also
products will be related to each other
like the cell phones like the routers
that you will produce d or / do they or
consists a circle themselves so how do
you see this difference we've thought
about all those through first we need a
utilized style in terms of the design
and the experience of our products so
the customer will have a similar
experience when they are using them
second our strategy the call of a
strategy is centered around the cell
phone to develop other derivatives so
the connection the connection
interconnection between different
products are very crucial for us we are
a open network which means our devices
can be connected with our own but also
with others that we're real value is
generated I agree now I'm a lot of
Chinese companies are doing software
hardware and the network and I make
integrated them into together into one
circle do you agree with this model I
think different companies may choose
different approaches for example show me
through equity investment to have
participate in other companies like I GE
and the yuku and to develop a interprets
connection with Internet industry which
is a more open approach so different
companies have different strategies
let's see like
three years later what a company will
show me become do you think you have
like a thousand show me family show me
stores around the country and what will
be the flagship product of show me is it
still the cell phone I think it would be
cell phone for at least three years then
what will be the echo chain of F show me
by then you have now 85 million users
which developed in the past years and in
the past six years you also developed a
product chain which is very
controversial after three years how
these two parts will develop or involve
do you have any like projection about
those two for me I think show me needs
to concentrate so we need to think clear
what we should do and what part should
be left to our partners and we are very
cautious on this for our own products
our own manufacturing is very limited
most part of our chain will be
outsourced to other partners we have two
chains now first is the internet chain
all the apps and devices and the
functions based on this network of show
me I think the scale of this chain
already surpassed the imagination of
many people in dismay we have more than
200 million users of the UI products I
mean the active users who actually use
our UI products is more than two
100 million and we have a 46 apps that
have active users more than 5 million
and we have a thousand apps who have
active users of more than 1 million
because I'm watching you totally out we
also invested in this app and the edn
machine they are all part of our
information chain so we have a system we
have a network here which reach out
deeply into this industry we covered
almost 100 the companies in this area so
we do this through equity investment and
other ways to participate in the UI
sector but we also have a smart as hot
where a network have several directions
first we need to connect all those
hardware devices together and we need to
be a leader in this area to have more to
extend our connections with others I
think it's a very valuable strategy the
thing is that now we have done we
haven't done enough it is very difficult
Apple and Google are trying to do the
same thing but is difficult is very
challenging to move forward why is that
first I think now we have solution for
one end connection from one end to
another show me develop the protocol for
this connection and even more we are
doing the model we are doing the cloud
ding service and we provide a
comprehensive solution for this once we
have this solution we tried it out with
different partners however this stew
very difficult for us to move forward on
this so in the last in the next 2-3
years you still concentrate on a circle
and
and try to expand it to other areas yes
we're trying to make it exclusive as
possible but it but now I just do very
challenging every company has the same
idea they want their own circle but the
would result in more difficulties in
connecting different circles together
because everyone every company has their
own philosophy on this and there is no
mature trust you always think your
standards your protocol is the best but
I don't want it have my own standards I
want to how nice myself with others we
don't want IP we don't want patent we
just ask for connection between now cell
phones with other systems with other
networks it is a very sounds like a
simple request however it is very
challenging it's very difficult to
realize everyone the carriers wants
their own network and it would be the
last resort for them to connect with
other carriers well the internet the
resource on the internet has been taken
by many participants is this historical
issue but now you are playing a very
unique role you are a participant in the
internet and you know your manufacturer
of hardware's how do you see this
relation if we do not produce those
devices instead we set up and standards
I don't see the visibility of this soil
strategy is we develop our system to
connect different ends different devices
all this system have my participation
and all of those devices can be easily
connected to my cell phone when those
devices is increasing then the edge the
advantage of this is charmaine network
will be more and more accurate to the
public so you need to do a lot of things
you need to connect to many other device
it's like the switch like the any like
household applications so the cell phone
will like a remote app to control all of
those devices yes exactly so this is a
very important goal of show me all our
standards or protocols are public to the
open to the public we are doing this as
a pilot program you need to demonstrate
how efficient or how practical this is
to the public to other participants at
the end of the day the volume of your
users will determine everything and the
standards always the most users will
become the universal standard I'm very
impressed by your interview the other
day you're saying that show me is a very
different Chinese company and today in
this annual meeting would you explain or
demonstrate how show me is different
from other Chinese companies well one
difficult difficulty I encountered ways
is that show me in terms of this
business model is very complicated
complexed company it hard to explain it
in a plain language this is one question
haunted me for the past 26 years so if
for a Malaysian audience who know
nothing about show me what would you say
to him of course you are not a food
producer we know that so to make things
easier I would explain I'm a cell phone
producer with their cell phones on
internet but you never it never occurred
to you to introduce yummy as a internet
company not just a cell producer cell
phone producer for a very simple reason
if you want me to explain the business
model of show me edible too
have an hour because they're different
perspective different angles to explain
it for example people knows as shown me
is a Chinese cellphone producer we know
that but how many people know that show
me is the number three ecommerce company
in China and how many know that china is
aiming to become the world leading
retail company in the world so that is
from the personal perspective and in
terms of internet now we have 200
million users we have a lot of coverage
you have a big coverage in country and
our network covers more than a hundred
companies and the partners which
surpassed already the imagination and
understanding of many people and now
show me already invested in 55 smart
hardware companies and the producers
which covered almost every aspects of
people's life just like shall we said we
have the air purifier we have the water
purifier we have strong we have the
household even the fans I love the fans
I I don't want advertise but it is very
good present product I don't mind if you
can give one free for each of us here
but it is the fan is so delicately
designed it needs no electricity then we
can notice the fan it is chart is
powered by battery so if there is
mosquito in your backyard you bring this
fan out with wireless it can move to
everywhere and if you you know go
outside in summer it's very convenient
so show me has a lot of smart products
which don't attract a lot of enough
attention because people only pay at
to some particular products of show me
so why would we do that because we have
a lot of rationals or reasons behind
this for example I said we want to
connect our cell phones to other devices
in yams secondly we want to make
ourselves as a Moche in the high tech we
need at least 50 excuse in our store but
a bigger reason is that we have found a
way to combine thinking with the
physical economy this as a way into
suiting you for others he says will help
with that we can help 100 industries
make improvement property with extreme
ways that we have for put 100 pieces the
catfish to stir the whole pound for
example one half years ago way started
our operations in a cell phone business
and after our were disturbance you see
some people are faced out somebody make
improvement that's our contribution in
the cell phone manufacturing in China
for example one year go with started
they have power outlet one year one year
and half ago and now we see that all the
Contra peers are making progress
although not as good as our product so
we hope that others that can make a
great efforts to surpass us so our
effort is now to face out everyone I
think that is the biggest amidst and
instead of us we don't think we have the
capacity and we don't think we have to
desire we don't make these house or go
our goal is to improve the whole
industry so in the past 30 years I
welcome all kinds of
no interaction we want to be present our
experiences with the peers other
companies even other industry for
example for the electric cook and the
two years ago I started this he says
that a better with doming to who is the
owner of the green and who is green a
chairman woman he said well we start we
started the Japanese electro cooks and
however you know with people started
because the the rice is better the water
is better actually no it's their devices
better because there is a macro pressure
available we've made the rice you know
cook rice for so many years but the best
is a 105 celsus degree and 1.2 air
pressure so the key is to doug is to
have the micro pressure and the wisdom
will learn to the product with different
brand called the media my family and we
started the market and found there was
no similar product in China no at the
products then the Japanese production so
words will not make the products we must
make something he says you know people
go to Japan to purchase the products for
five thousand armed be after the Chinese
manufacturing manufactures made a
similar he says our products and 999 rd
yes it's very simple because without it
our cost it's very simple so I what I'm
saying it's really valuable it's an
improvement of deficiency besides for
the garment and we talked about so
example to rmb yourselves to call stuff
for sale for six hundred because of
distribution because of the inventory
cost anna some return of the goose may
be costly move 35% for the attack
electric home appliance the
margins not high the advertisements the
six to eight percent of the distribution
of about the eight to nine percent and
about the white and black home appliance
legend says if you study further it says
not possible I will not you elaborate on
the trade secrets because that may be
offensive to many people you point out
to anyone if you point anyone have
in-depth started anything what is the
average cost it includes multiple
factors first day is the rebate how much
you sell it and be attained be aware of
food the operational cost of furnish and
you also have you need sales
representatives inhibitory and the power
bill is much more than you thought so
today most of the products and half of
it even more than of a tease in the
distribution how they sell it to you so
I will not elaborate on the trade
secrets many people think that a show me
is a business model that's the only
advantage actually we have other reasons
more complicated than the many people
think how to make your product great
then cut down the cost that's a big
challenge traditionally many
manufactures for example make 100 models
for the same development if you have 100
types of for the inventories the models
why don't you focus only 11 model if you
are traditional manufacture need 100
models from the same development and to
occupy the market to to make the shelf
for full there were many reasons but
only fuse two sentences I win so why
don't you elaborate I to Davos just WTF
i said i was going only given few
45 minutes actually the in the
traditional model is that's the way to
make you know elaborate make blah blah
blah things for example TV set for 80
inches the cheapest man will be 2,000
rmb then we'll tell me that that is not
available data and overland only let you
know that only the most expensive is
available then you pay for 6,000 are
being probably for the same products so
with the 2,000 depressed tech to attract
you in the store and to bombard you with
10,000 and salad for 6,000 the mcs that
you will be hated after this the WFO
actually there is a minor difference
whether it's between different models so
I tracked you with the two thousand and
bombard you with 10,000 1746 thousand
why don't you focus on single product
your core product the best product
because with the Internet era with the
information a disclosure you can now to
for your consumers and you only make one
part for example 100 only one size TV
set of salads for one-third of the pier
products mr. Wu you are the expert but
actually I'm the people in the feud I'm
thinking of this all these years so how
to make a great product and how to lower
down the counselor with a massive
production and not only show me but also
others with ecosystem we only focus on
one product usually to source the best
experts and at all costs to make one
product in 12 years with rd import a
massive import to make one great product
you know we developed the our power
outlet with our divestment alpha 10
million rmb you know we spend the tens
of the regular efforts to make a great
product I think that's the best way to
optimize your costs you know this is
always standards you make
10 million or 20 million production you
know the traditional way is to 100
models with only well two thousand four
years the cost is very high for
maintaining some managerial things
everything is extensive a very important
the business concept here is that what
we are advocating is to partner with the
users make friends with of your users
you don't do fool your friends it's
100.com are because you don't sell it
for 1,000 if your friends knows you're
constantly to 100 then your friends will
be useful to discover the cost and the
retail price don't know can be with that
ties you know me for years resume and
people often argue that why don't you
give me a discount if it was a
15-percent discount no I cannot because
with others at the cost this isn't you
know that bad practice of traditional
business model so I'm often thinking and
say that important new business
innovation is that treat your users as a
friends not you know all those people
that who say in their treaty Oh
customers as their goals are you know
kind of food jerk or things and you know
if you are seeing your customers are
gotta treat your friends treating your
customers of fools you know that some
bite guides actively you know I say so
we always treat our users as friends and
thank you very much undulating and back
to the year 2010 the show me applied
into thinking to the cell phone
manufacturing and there were many
followers and that has created a new
trend in the manufacturing sector now
today the tangi summer Davos WF we
talked about the transition industrial
transition I believe we shall me at
least is a
typical success story in the transition
with we take this as a case study we may
ask you a question you know show me is
diversifying in many complicated for
example a shammy family to the 20,000
the connection a merely users ecosystem
much more sophisticated as your model
can be copied in China or in the world
the last question if your model can be
copied I think it really depends on what
level when I started the dashami had
Waco system we are trying to answer this
question many people was thinking what's
questioning that our businesses could
not be copied so what is well that is
then there is a miracle he says actually
we can't copy we're helping 50 companies
who are copying us you see many things
that are not manufactured to us for
example by some projector companies how
to make our product as the icon product
so from our manufacturing as yummy is
great actually they can copy your cell
phone model to make electric cooker but
what about the greater expected the show
me in general and for lenovo y mae algo
me can they copy your business model he
says I think it's very difficult the
most difficult part is that it is a
hardware software and the internet
ecosystem is a fusion you know few
companies that have such DNA available
to branch in the hardware software and
the internet they pick it's the
challenge that it needs one a group of
people who have food all the things in
one how can you be such a person is that
a good question I think I started this
company with that basic idea so in our
early days we have the people from four
major companies motorola
the google and the kingsoft you know we
try to make out of the great person
until the I'm person to make houses from
the eight co-founders you know to make a
I'm people team when like one single
person cannot make a successful so we
have the founders from for top hardware
and software companies in the world so
we are trying to from the very first day
to make a I people race what his big is
concerned I don't have concerns so what
I was thinking what is the top of mind
every day so he says for me how to make
the product each product a great product
I think that's the core thing what do i
doing don't elaborate on others consumer
experience you know unparallel consumer
experience or products experience is the
greater things do you have time reading
he says he's a bookworm he's a he's a
fan before he started show me he dressed
in shorts and read books every day and
round in the city he says not much as
before but definitely the world two
hours every day you know we usually
spend about two hours on cell phone last
a question so when would you have the
IPO of show me besides from the very big
first day that not in the five years
today I can say that another five years
actually the Xiaomi pissants not all
from the first I believe we need 15
years at the least of all IPO so why
don't you let us know you know earlier
he says well if I say 15 years people
will think I'm fooling everyone so I
process as a naughty first 25 years
because we believe show me needs to be
trusted by consumers from bottom their
heart so often an i nine years you still
don't have IPO he says first we have
this business model accepted by our
consumers and you should understand and
accept now we are in the second phase
that is
the food make ourselves as of fuji in
high tech sector this is something we
wanted to do it six years ago now it's
only the time now we can have it tense
for to have the fusion of online and
offline to launch the branding now if we
make it as well whether you when you
review our development you understand
that you can understand our business
model thank you very much mr. Duchin for
sharing it as so many secrets you're
inside thank you very much